all right Camila did you ever do
anything when you're a kid like make did
I do anything to make movies make movies
I am I am I have lost my laptop that had
my photo booth on it uh in my early
teenage years and I don't know where it
is it's voted with a not Tick Tock wow
well I don't know what's on there for
like a five-year period of my life and
I've lost it but I just I just imagine
like that I just remember being like I
was like a sad sad girl like like a Lana
Del Rey no no I was I would put it on I
do like I would do like sad music videos
like looking out like the window and it
was raining so dramatic listening to
Lana Del Rey and being like yeah my life
is sweet like cinnamon
I just had like simply emotional YouTube
uh photo booth videos yeah and I don't
know where they are today I did that to
tattoo but I was older than you oh yeah
oh my God I remember photo booths there
was Lana Del Rey there was like a lot of
like we were just in our feelings and
like as like a 13 year old girl puberty
it's hard
oh yeah she was
this was my Alanis Morissette that was
my that was yeah and I was like wait
women can say this yeah I was like
people are in the South aren't allowed
to say this if you're a girl
um love her
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]